[Music]
hey did you guys see this posted all
over social media what is that air
strikes in the last 48 it was a graphic
that said condemn war everywhere and it
showed like all these other areas
37 saudi air strikes in yemen exactly
u.s airstrike in some syria uh israel
israeli airstrike in damascus dozens of
russian airstrikes in ukraine yeah so
everyone's just talking about one thing
wow like what we've been talking about
the whole [ __ ] time who's responsible
for all those other airstrikes the
united states all of them just about
yeah but are we protecting democracy
we are protecting
the saudis interests in wanting to
destroy the [ __ ] out of yemen so that's
what's going on because saudis are
friends because they
we buy oil from them so this graphic
went around man and a bunch of uh
like leftist political pages and igs
were just reposting the crap out of this
and then now they're all pissed only
leftist interesting they're all pissed
because this was a kremlin-made image
really the russian government created
this to get the attention off of just
russia and ukraine
like look
you guys been doing this i mean that is
the russian narrative right it's kind of
like the west always comes in with the
idea of like we're trying to save
democracy but then yeah
but then also i guess uh russia plays a
big role in the in the bombings in syria
as well
absolutely even though it's criminally
made uh is it all true though yes
it is but um
when it takes away from
ukraine right now but that but that okay
that's such a misnomer anyway because
the ukraine's being talked about so much
already if anything the wars in yemen
are not being talked about at all
oh yeah those that's one of them
in the middle east and anything that
happens in africa like no one gives a
[ __ ] like it's sad because there's
millions of people that have died and
have gone forgotten because the western
media just doesn't cover it well yeah
for sure like if they do they always
cover it in a way where it's like we're
out there fighting terrorism look at
israel bro we israel bombs the absolute
[ __ ] out of the palestinians and
how do we cover it self-defense
good for them fighting terrorism every
time every time yeah it's such a touchy
subject though because they've been
warned for so [ __ ] long especially
with all this stuff in syria it's been
happening for so long yeah and i mean
and and russia
went into syria and took out isis
themselves so it's like oh and we were
allied with isis in syria
yeah we're with we're with the uh the
tower i'm sorry the al-qaeda yeah yeah
not isis yeah not isis in syria well
during the cold war no recently we were
allied with al-qaeda in syria damn but
we i mean not not officially we were
just fighting the same side all against
a common enemy against assad yeah it
always flips back and forth and stuff
what's weird to me is like okay so right
now there's this whole war [ __ ] right
and they're talking about you know how
we basically
gotta suffer with the gas prices and
whatever
we're still buying gas from iran we're
still buying gas from like these
countries that i'm like should we really
be buying energy from and russia
i'm like russia has that pipeline that
goes to germany and it was like um
during trump's administration there was
this one
clip that's been going around of trump
basically talking to the dude in germany
like hey is it a conflict of interest if
you're a part of nato and all of your
energy is coming from russia what if
something happens here and you guys
are getting energy from russia but then
you have to punish them
so it's like and then now it's kind of
unfolding right we see germany actually
now throwing in like weapons to help uh
ukraine and all that but then for me i'm
like
this is weird because why are we doing
business or buying oil and having a
dependency from countries that we're
supposed to be
looking at as enemies isn't that isn't
that [ __ ] weird it's gone to the
point where uh elon musk yesterday just
tweeted about how we need to ramp up and
he said i hate to say this but we need
to ramp up oil production in america
that's actually the solution because
because they can't spin up ev yeah
that's the problem right just to
complete his thought they can't just all
of a sudden have enough support with
solar and wind and all that stuff to
make up for what we're doing with oil
it's not as efficient right
with elon's point though if we did that
we don't have to buy from iran and all
these other countries we don't have to
make them rich if we just crank up the
production of oil ourselves but
what's happening there where we don't
just crank it up here it's against the
well you know environmentalists there's
a lot of environmental interests about
it which i'm not saying i'm for against
i'm just saying
i understand the realities of like our
situation right now and the need to tap
into our our our ability to produce oil
in the united states because of all
these externalities is that well do you
want to help russia finance their war
that that's how they're paying for the
war right now with oil money so we need
we need oil right now so you're making
their oil more valuable is that why
everyone's fighting over like what's
more important climate change or winning
this war because this whole new argument
has been [ __ ] weird to me it's like
why are people talking about global
warming warning warming like we're not
going to have a world to worry about
global warming warning and [ __ ] like you
can walk and chew gum at the same time
though right so it's like if you if you
really believe in something and you want
to like maybe iterate your
production towards a certain thing i can
understand that but it's about accepting
reality sometimes too so it's like hey
because we can um
we can produce all these green energy
alternatives the yield's not there yet
so you have to start looking at reality
yeah and so the reality is right now we
don't have the technological like
capabilities right this minute to do it
so we still rely on or just to slice
infrastructure to stop completely doing
something else yeah exactly
yeah it's gotta happen at the same time
right like upping the oil production in
america in order to like sustain that
moment but also reducing the consumption
of oil in america at the same time by
using things like eevee and alternative
would be great but but even when you use
ev what are you doing right you're right
you're plugging in the wall so you're
using coal so it's like there's just so
much going on like it's it's not just a
easy like hey we this just fixes all
that
like ev equals coal more coal being
burned so
yeah they should have elected me for the
department of energy
because aren't you the officer of the
interior it hurt when you lost you hurt
when you lost that campaign i thought i
was running for politics joe's running
for paul
if you guys want to see the campaign ad
too it's really it's really specific
dude joe's running for everything man
he's taking over nothing but ram baby
but um no seriously guys like i think
i'm gonna run for the department of
energy
because we are in an energy crisis and
if we're gonna depend on so many
countries that violate humans rights and
stuff i'm like why should we make them
rich right
now there's an unlimited source of
energy that we're not tapping into
campfires
what in the actual you have my full
attention
yeah you know how did how are campfires
in renewable again
oh jesus
that's all huh
here's the thing okay
what do they say is uh as is is is
always is causing the [ __ ] ozone
layer to [ __ ] uh cow farts exactly
right
farts gas methane from the human and
animals all over the body now i watched
matrix and i said if we could use human
batteries right it's good we can use
human farm we're going to power our
country
for farting and capturing the energy of
those gases from every household in
america every household we just need
texas to be involved and we're good
that's true everything is bigger in
texas everything's well yeah though some
of those south american countries they
got those giant [ __ ] blimps that
they're just burning [ __ ] and like trash
and they're able to use that as a way to
power stuff oh yeah like in that one uh
uh netflix documentary that had the uh
zac efron dude
his name is zac efron that's what it is
i was like zac efron guy yeah he went to
one of those little communities and they
had this giant tanks where everybody's
[ __ ] feces and farts not just but
like feces and stuff goes in there but
yeah if we could do more of that [ __ ]
what about burps where does burps fall
into i would collect it all
joe has this extreme view where you
collect all of it
wow no matter how you do it it's pretty
crazy you know how elon has his dream
right of like the solar [ __ ] and you can
install it in your house and that not
only powers your house but then it has
an excess of electricity and it goes
into right and also has a nice tesla
logo on it yeah you know you know what
what about that black mirror episode and
i always honestly thought this was uh
would make a lot of sense you remember
that one episode where uh everybody's
like
cycling
for energy classic right there's so much
um
i'm not saying so much like a power of
the entire [ __ ] country but like
there's so many people that do use human
energy and expense at cycling running or
whatever if there was a way to harness
that that physical exercise and just
turn it into something i feel like i
wish it would work but it's not that
good like you you
damn for example having a damn is way
more beneficial to people yeah the
hoover dam you guys should go to the
hoover dam and go to the hoover dam tour
and understand
the [ __ ] magnitude of that [ __ ] how
much electricity it provides for
southern california the desert cities
all this [ __ ] nevada all those states
just from that one little same people
are exercising okay yeah he's trying to
spread a positive message they're
exercising know that this had to do with
the hoover dam we just have to harness
the kinetic energy of the people touring
the hoover dam oh
yeah cuz some malls they got that tile
they have that tile every time you step
on it right and it produces power on the
other end oh there you go so what we
need to do is create new homes where
they have exercise bikes
fart
hole suckers yeah four holes gas stuff
sounds like a band
sucker
and we need to make it like a collective
war effort
like you know when there's a drought
right they go if it's brown flush it
down if it's yellow let it mellow says
that during droughts not rich people
really no they they taught us this well
yeah we we do it but the rich people
don't what about a flat a fleshlight
that has a battery on the other end i
knew this was going to happen i couldn't
i was waiting
for the mouse to drop yourself off and
then you charge up a battery and it uses
the power supply if they could harness
the power of masturbation of
masturbation
yo we would overpower they already have
that it's an attachment that goes into
your prius where the tailpipe would be
oh
but don't you guys think it's a little
too op
it is look like everything would blow up
it needs it
yeah yeah it's true you want too much
power yeah you're gonna use it too much
oh yeah so this is another little thing
but that image of the airstrike thing
that was posted the day of the invasion
by redfish that company that uh
is responsible for all these posts but
one thing that's crazy and i didn't know
this but you guys remember the um
remember rt
yeah of course russia russia today the
production company that runs rt america
shut down and laid off all its employees
on thursday what
well didn't they block to get blocked by
facebook everything's getting blocked
yeah
if it's the russian message message is
getting blocking yeah russia didn't
russia just shut down facebook in their
country yeah
wait what came first did russia block
facebook or did facebook block itself
from in russia i think facebook blocked
russian uh media
um not russians but then russians said
that's unfair we are now blocking
russian media yeah that's like a you
can't fire me i quit
i like that
was asking for
internet for like starlink or whatever
right and then because they're all their
infrastructures all [ __ ] up and then
elon's like done that's great and he
still kept it real with the updates he's
like in these areas some of them have
gone down blah blah blah but like
they're the the link or whatever has
already been patched let us know how
it's going excited to see how this works
listen the idea that we have to protect
people from the perspectives of others
because they won't be able to make up
their own minds as nuts yeah and that
just makes me believe in like there's
just a police state mentality going on
where everyone just wants everyone to
think one thing and the other thing
should be banned always should be wrong
no matter what like i don't care what
the [ __ ] going on i know because i
feel like i'm
you know reasonable enough to see both
sides and i think that i'm past the idea
of we're good guys they're bad guys like
i know that all [ __ ] states are
hungry for power and so
why can't we listen to the different
narratives to figure out
what is the motive between these two
great nations that are trying to
consolidate power essentially is what it
is
i'm just glad that u.s imperialism is
done for
they haven't tried to do anything that
doesn't even exist because it's always
been for democracy and moral victory
liberating people yeah that's why you're
running for politics man good i hope you
win and it's like hey that's a swish for
joe
right through the rim
you